today we're gonna examine the future of
gentle criminal after he was mercilessly
beaten ambushed and robbed by the
alleged hero in training uzuki midoriya
no but in all seriousness gentle
criminal is down for the count and just
like I did with my videos for overhaul
and myrio this video here will confirm
whether gentle all the braava appear
again in the series and then after that
we'll also theorize about their future
beyond that so starting with whether
these two return to the series after
gentles fight with Deku the short answer
is that they only make one more
appearance after the battle is over
however a character that is connected to
gentle also makes another appearance
that we'll get to in a bit we see that
both gentle and lebra
are in a police station being
interviewed by the offices and they're
trying to work out whether the lebra
has been brainwashed by gentle this
guerrilla guy looks over gentles record
and from the interaction it's pretty
clear that gentles villain days are over
now while it says here that a lot of his
crimes were only attempted crimes we did
see firsthand that he beat down a group
of pro heroes and threatened a guy at
knifepoint and this is just me
speculating here but I mean you can't
say he doesn't deserve at least a tiny
bit of jail time just a teeny bit it's
heavily implied that gentle will now go
on to turn his life around but that
might take a while
as this gorilla guy tells gentle that
the only people who don't change are
those who are impatient and what the
result straightaway so in my opinion
that's probably horikoshi foreshadowing
that gentle rebuilding his life is
probably gonna take a while now to put
this all into perspective the events I
just described happen in Chapter 183 of
the manga with a typical episode on
average adapting about three chapters
now that varies on a case-by-case basis
and there are obviously many examples
where this is not the case but three
chapters per one episode is the rough
average bearing that in mind as of
recording this video the manga is
currently on chapter 264 and we've not
seen either gentle all a brava during
this period and when we use this very
unscientific three chapter rule there's
at least 26 more episodes in which we
will not be seen gentle criminal which
is just over a full season so you know
not too long I mean if you think about
it we haven't seen staying for up I mean
even longer than that so so there is
still potential for gentle to return
sooner than staying returns but putting
that aside while we haven't actually
seen these two like I said earlier we
have seen someone that gentle is
connected to
so gentles highschool friend called
Takeshita who eventually became a pro
hero and was kind of the one who
inadvertently inspired gentles criminal
career this guy actually appears in
Chapter 260 of the manga as he was
helping out some other pro heroes with
something good to see he's still doing
well but yeah sorry that was literally
year like he just makes that one cameo
so yeah I mean as far as gentle and his
inner circle goes that is the extent of
it guys and with that all explained
let's get into the four most realistic
paths for the future of gentle and lebra
I'll preface this by saying that I do
actually believe they will make a return
gentle is just too good of a character
to never hear from him again
and unlike overhaul or miryo he wasn't
defeated in a way that renders him
powerless or crippled so for that reason
gentle not returning to this series is
actually not one of the four options on
this list the first most realistic
theory I have ties into the events that
are going on in the mag right now so if
you don't want to know any spoilers then
skip to the timestamp on-screen but for
the rest of you I think it's fair to say
that given that this war is now fully
underway there might come a time very
soon in which the heroes need to seek
refuge remember this guy's during the
endeavor agency arc both Hawkes and
endeavor acknowledged that these kids
are the insurance but if the heroes were
to lose the war in fact that was the
entire reason why endeavor bit the
bullet and decided to Train Deku I'm
back ago as well as Todoroki horikoshi
didn't put that in there for giggles my
friends when the heroes lose there could
come a moment where the kids are on the
run without any adult supervision
because you know the adult son will be
massacred killed and turned into no
mousse whatever happens I don't know
about you but I can so pitch a gentle
and lebra
offering Deku orb a cougar or hell the
whole of class 1-a I can so imagine them
offering them a place to stay at least
for a period of time even though gentles
plan was to invade UA remember that it
was partly his own twisted way of
actually strengthening the kids
long-term if his mission was successful
he actually wanted everyone to learn
from the experience so he does have
compassion like I think that much is
clear and throughout his petty crimes he
always had good intentions so to me if
he's in the process of turning his life
around this would make perfect sense and
following on from this if society was to
just crumble under the villains he
wouldn't exactly need a hero license to
use his quirk witty and therefore he
could help the kids out in battle and
pretend
to get this matchup which I've talked
about in a previous video this genuinely
is like guys you don't understand this
is like one of the top five things I
need to happen I just I hope you all
know that but moving on the second most
realistic path for gentle is that if
society doesn't crumble he actually
returns in the future as a pro hero now
hear me out here in the spin-off
tomorrow academia Ingenium who is 10
years older brother offered a character
the chance to earn his provisional
license qualification little by little
this is proof that in the world of my
year academia there are alternative ways
to become a licensed hero beyond the
typical route that we see most heroes
take and it makes sense too because in
the real world there are lots of ways
for adults to get qualifications that
are typically done by younger people
whether that be doing night classes or
whatever and I know that being a
professional hero is a pretty unique
profession but let's consider two things
firstly the Public Safety Commission did
say that since almost retirement Society
does need more heroes and specifically
ones that can collaborate and work well
together bearing that in mind few
characters would work better together as
a hero team than gentle and lebra
secondly remember that there are
literally thousands of licensed Pro
heroes out there right most of them who
we don't even know about I imagine that
if he was to acquire his hero license he
would have a relatively average rank but
be undeterred in his quest to rise up
the ranks and become the number one hero
in fact in all likelihood just for
comedic effect
I reckon la Bravo would probably end up
surpassing him in the hero rankings sort
of like Jennison Saitama that that type
of thing but being serious guys gentles
dream was to become a pro hero and this
whole villain fantasy it was just one
way of him kind of reaching that goal in
a very twisted way so the idea that he
would get on the right track and become
a licensed actual pro hero if it's
possible for him to do it at his age I
think this is gonna happen and perhaps
we see him again in a few years time now
the third most realistic possibility for
gentle is that he doesn't become a hero
but that he and LeBron used their skills
to work for a hero agency following on
from what I mentioned earlier eaters
older brother had a hero agency right
and in the agency he employed not just
heroes but other important jobs like
navigators and support staff who assists
on hero duties this is also paralleled
by all my and nite ize relationship
where night I was purely based in the
office and did a lot of strategize
in paperwork so with LeBron is epic
hacking skills and gentles unrivaled
tea-making ability they'd be a great
addition to any hero agency and wouldn't
it be cool if in two years time when
Deku graduates if society hasn't been
completely obliterated that deck who
starts his own hero agency and highs
gentle and lebra
and that wouldn't be too bizarre as we
know that both hawks and Endeavor
started their own hero agencies at very
young ages so in conclusion this theory
is that gentle and the braava will
support a hero agency in working behind
the scenes and it could potentially be
Dec who's won as well
I mean Dec is a nice guy he would do
that right now the final idea I have is
what if gentle becomes a vigilante now a
vigilante for those of you who don't
know it's basically an illegal hero
who's operating without a license and
doing this would still be a criminal act
hence why I'm a bit skeptical as to
whether gentle would want to go down
this path because if he's truly gonna
turn his life around he can't be still
committing crimes following this path
would allow him to use his quirk which
he's seemingly mastered over the years
so it would be a waste if he wasn't able
to use his quirk going forward right
considering how well he uses it and
crucially this would also give him
another avenue in which to become famous
online as instead of recording his
crimes he could record his heroic acts
which I guess would still technically be
crimes because he doesn't have a hero
license thinking about it that way I'm
actually not sure if there's a way
around this conundrum like the police
will still be looking for him however it
is still infinitely better than us never
seeing him again so yeah I'd take this
over that but what do you guys think
which is the most likely theory to
happen for gentle criminal I kind of
refused to believe the her akashi would
just waste this character forever so I'm
gonna say that he will come back as like
a low-level pro hero or someone's
sidekick potentially and knowing her
Rico she will likely get like a blurry
cameo of him before this is actually
fully revealed anyway thanks for
watching as always and don't forget to
subscribe and remember that I have a new
video coming out tomorrow that
summarizes the pro hero arc but with
that said peace out